the Spartan veterans at practice these
players are a few of the 60 000
cameroonians who live in the US the
majority here in Maryland and they'll be
watching as the team called the
indomitable Lions attempt to claw their
way back just as they did to beat
Algeria in the final minutes of a
must-win qualifier the shorts are
maturity but you know with us watching
and knowing what soccer is and what you
know Cameroon is capable of doing we
still see a lot of mistakes that they
make you know and we hope you know
they've been able to you know have some
good guidance and will still calm and
you know a standard test we go take that
cup
they work under a lot of pressure during
qualifying but it seems that they
took the pressure and they seem to
mature as they went through qualifying
do you do you think that that this is
the right time for them this is the
right time for them because they have to
let the world know that qualifying it's
a hard job it was not just a fluke
while the players were at their
pre-tournament Camp civil unrest
continued back home and some expatriate
supporters have mixed feelings about
supporting a team that they maintain
have been used by the government to
divert attention from its shortcomings
yeah it's really difficult I mean and
sports has always been used as I mean
soccer especially spot washing in back
home again like the African nation cup
that was organized I mean there was a
lot of trouble back home and then those
things were being done but they again I
think it's really really difficult for a
lot of cameroonians with what is going
back home with all the um struggles and
so on it's difficult to support soccer
despite his reservations kalei and
Sunday will be watching with his friends
willing Cameroon to fight back once
again
hi Hannah Al Jazeera Columbia Maryland